you know one of the bestselling books in
the 9s this is after Mosaic it was a
book in the bookstore how to get on the
internet you had to download drivers and
windows that's of course why AOL became
they literally said finally it's so hard
we're going to send you CDs because this
is just a nightmare because you had to
literally go and be like a hacker just
to install the windows dri I realized
email marketing was going to be big and
in 1997 every human that walked into the
Wine Library that bought serious wine I
was like would you like to join our
email newsletter half of them didn't
know what email was the remaining 25%
there was 25% that new would say
something like yeah my email is AOL
yahoo.com like they they didn't have it
calibrated attention is the number one
asset vayer Nation how are you uh very
excited about this interview as you know
most of what I'm doing is uh group
settings in podcast in 2024 podcast with
friends that I uh stream live on Twitch
go to Twitch go to Gary ve.com twitch
all of you should be subbing up but this
one's a special episode because I think
um I think a lot about filming myself
over the last 15 20 years and something
happened when I was with a couple of
buddies on my team a couple months ago
where we looked back at Old footage from
my daily vog even just six seven years
ago and I already got what I wanted out
of this which was the fondness of
looking back at things I have a I'm
making a prediction that I will look at
this interview in 30 40 50 years with
Incredible fondness and so I'm glad that
I still look somewhat decent cuz I have
a feeling this will be important video
that I watch and my grandkids watch um
my guest today is Chris Dixon he wrote a
new book uh and it's an important book
uh read write own Chris is someone I've
gotten to know a lot better in the last
three four years but when that started
happening when we started talking and um
he's got an incredible career as a
founder and definitely as an investor um
it was really funny when I could tell
that like oh I feel like Chris and I are
going to get closer I called AJ and I
said bro guess what I've been talking to
a little bit lately and he said oh I
said Chris Dixon and he laughed with a
laugh that you could only know when you
have a brother which was he knew why it
mattered to me I navigated
2006 to
2011 as an essential point in my career
it's when I transitioned from running a
liquor store to starting to become an
angel investor and really my talk about
your you know to me that was like going
away to college that era of the internet
I really became dramatically more uh
educated on many things and I it was
also during an era where a lot of the
people from 20034 five were writing
blogs and blogs were such an essential
part of the internet and then Twitter
came along and things started to shift
but I consumed an enormous amount of
information from so many different
people in that 5-year window and
literally literally there was only a
couple people that
consistently would say things I'm like
yep yep yep and as you can imagine
because I felt that I had a good eye on
where the world was going that made me
think that they were smart I agreed and
and obviously it all kind of a lot of
those things played out
Chris literally one of I mean genuinely
one of two or three people that I was
like wow this guy gets it gets it gets
it gets it and when I found myself
getting deeper and deeper into web 3
sure enough he was there again and again
gets it gets it gets it so it's a real
honor for me Chris to have on the show
thank you so much Gary I I my audience
knows that that setup is unheard of for
me and so I think everyone's we better
not blow it now yeah big big trouble we
got to those and likewise like you know
I think of you as one of the kind of
fellow Travelers who have been through
multiple eras of the internet and have
always been I think optimistic um
embracing new technologies leaning into
it um and I and I have a lot of respect
for that and so I was excited when I you
know when we got the chance again to or
I guess for the first
conferences here and there yeah it had
been informal before so I was very
excited to get to work work with form
and that sets up this whole thing let me
just go right into it uh we're now we we
filmed this a little bit earlier but
like this is out now on podcast in all
my socials Clips we're pushing it today
because it's release dat January 30th I
I couldn't recommend more especially
because so many of you have been vriends
or vriends curious crypto or crypto
curious nft this blockchain that deep
fake videos like I know who's listening
all the way from the kids on the come up
who who are excited about it to all of I
I probably want the Fortune 500 the
policy makers the the small business
owners to read this even more this
book has the potential again no pressure
has the potential to be the
quintessential book that allowed people
to get it the AHA as we transition from
Web Two to web three there's so much you
know not misinformation there's so much
uh misunderstanding of this next era I
think Chris has done a phenomenal job at
taking a stab at it and so again the
reason I said that I might look back on
as fondly is I think it'll be fun to
look at I know we'll be friends in 40
years and like we had hair and and I
have a feeling like this book could be
that book and so it's an important time
too because I do think right now we're
in an inflection point of people trying
to understand this fully but are ready
to understand it so very simply my first
maybe only question cuz I think we can
rant on this and flow is why did you
write this book now and what is the book
about yeah so you know I've been spent
my whole career on the internet I I am
basically 25 years um working on the
internet in some way or another I was an
entrepreneur I started two companies and
then became an investor um tell
everybody what those companies are yeah
so and just going back by the way like I
was just my own background like I you
know I came from Ohio my parents were
professors I was actually in a PhD
program in philosophy believe it or not
um lot because I think most of the
reasons I've always had nodded with you
is I think you understand human
behavior that makes a lot of sense so so
you know so I um and that was sort of
late 90s and then I discovered for me it
was a real real kind of epiphany was to
discover that there was a job you could
do which was to you know like start
companies and do this cool stuff and
then specifically on the internet and
and for me what was attractive about the
internet for those who kind of know the
Internet history and I go through some
of this in the book is the idea that it
would be this network that connects all
the computers and all the people in the
world but it would be a network owned by
the people right it would be
democratically controlled right anyone
that was the original Pro that was the
original internet and and and the idea
anyone could go and put up a website you
could be an artist a poet a programmer
an entrepreneur whatever you whatever
you want to do and you could put up a
website and you could go and build an
audience and have a direct relationship
with that audience and maybe that's
something you do for fun or maybe you
you know you put ads up or you sell
products
but whatever you want to do you can do
and you have this little plot of land
your your website you know amazon.com
became a very big plot of land some of
these little plots of land became big I
have a little plot of land C dixon. org
but you got a little plot of land right
you got a little plot of land and you
could build on it and you knew if you
built on it that you would own it right
that you would own what you built so you
know Jeff Bezos and Mark Zuckerberg and
Larry Page and all these people who were
building these startups and I I believe
a lot of the entrepreneurship that led
to the original kind of growth of the
internet was was because people were
attracted to that promise 100% right I
told my father that wine library.com
which I launched in 1997 for a single
store liquor store in New Jersey was
going to be our second location y we
were going to own this store and you
owned it right you own you own that
website and and that that was you know
that and that there's a whole history to
that how that happened like that
architecture of the internet it came out
of government and Academia I go through
it briefly in the book I go through the
kind of important points I try not to
bog it down with too much history but
that's been well covered too yeah but I
go through the sort of salient points
and specifically it was architect in a
way that you sort of owned some you had
ownership and specifically like of your
domain or of your email address and that
gave you all these rights and G let you
build a direct audience and that was a
very important sort of what seems like a
kind of Arcane technical feature that
you could own your domain and that for
example if your hosting provider
misbehaves you can switch your domain to
somebody else you control it right and
that that's a very important uh feature
that yeah that basically shifted power
to the to the edges of the network to
the users the creators and the
entrepreneurs and so that was great and
then you know the internet sort of
continued to you know obviously there
was the internet bubble and then crash
in the 2000s and then kind of I think
when you got involved um and you know
and and I was involved then too um that
was sort of the you know the kind of
rebirth the web 2 era right and that's
when people started to realize that that
the internet wouldn't so in the sort of
first
era most of the websites were were I
call I call it skoric it's a term that
Steve Jobs used to refer to software
that kind of looks like old-fashioned
things like the original Apple uh uh
book book app had sort of grainy book
looks and stuff that was a Steve Jobs
term but it's come to mean something
broader which is sort of when when a new
medium pops up like the internet people
do things like they take magazines and
brochures and basically make digital
versions of right and that was kind of
you know I think probably most listeners
always take the last form factor into
the new like early films were plays
essentially we're at Vayner media and
advertising firm the first 100 TV
commercials were radio ads yep a man sat
there and read so you always sort of
Port the last for of media so right so
the so the web by the way if I may I
apologize it's why social media
marketing is misunderstood you still
have TV Centric advertising agencies
trying to make ads on social media that
are made for television that's why all
those YouTube commercials stink they
shouldn't be that they should be YouTube
pre-roll ads not a television commercial
run as a pre-roll yeah and that's a
that's a repeating pattern right so
whenever something new comes along um
this is sort of you go to like media
studies and read like Marshall MCL and
these kinds of people they'll talk about
it which is a new medium comes new form
of media comes along and people start
off sort of doing the last thing and
then there's a few people like you who
are kind of pioneers but then eventually
other people figure it out that's right
and the specific new thing you could do
with the internet in the 2000s was it
was a two-way it was a publishing medium
it wasn't just it was that's why I call
it read it was it's a first one was sort
of read only you're consuming
information the 2000s in the web 2
movement people said hey what about if
anyone can not only read but they can
write they can publish right and that
was the beginning of blogging in the
early two I mean there was some blogging
but really in Earnest to begin 200000
was popular news site as you remember
called read write web there was there
was in fact I I quoted in the book and
their first thing their their actually I
quote their first paragraph which was
the web should be more than about it was
like 2003 they put up a Manifesto the
web should be more than about reading
information it should be about reading
and writing I love it and in fact they
other name for web too there were
conferences the read WR they were called
yeah so this is not by the some people
ask me like read WR did you make it no
no read wr's an old term the own is the
sort of new part and so anyways but
that's where the that's where the um
title comes from but um so anyway so
then so then the internet kind of grew
and that was great um but then the way I
think about it is it was sort of a
battle in the late 2000s between when
social networking got big between open
and closed architectures and so open
specifically there was a protocol called
RSS and people still use it for
podcasting and stuff and it's still
around but it's like you know tens of
millions of users not billions of users
the way that Facebook has right and so
what happened essentially and the way
that a lot of us thought it could get to
yeah and so at one point it was sort of
a it was sort of a legitimate rival to
Twitter and Facebook and everything else
and then around you know
2010ish the the clo the the the
corporate owned networks the sort of
proprietary networks like Facebook and
Twitter started to pull ahead um and
fast forward today you know that they're
now dominant and fast forward today you
now have um you know the top 1% of of
social networks control 95% of the
traffic top 1% of search engines 95% of
the search traffic the you know NASDAQ
um the top five tech companies went from
25% of the M NASDAQ uh market cap 10
years ago to 50% today wow like so all
of these stats consolid yeah it's just
massive consolidation and my concern and
I think we're really headed there is the
internet's going to end up like old
broadcast TV where you're going to have
ABC CBS and NBC you're going to have you
know Tik Tok Facebook Twitter and like
five things and you're already seeing
this by the way like you know Twitter is
demoting if you link out like you're not
only going to have five things but
they're going to be completely closed
silos and there going to be they're
going to these organisms are going to
care about themselves they're going to
care about themselves and so this the
internet will have gone from I what I
think of as this sort of beautiful open
dream of like this Democratic internet
into this into what I think is is really
not a great outcome which is uh an
internet of you know sort of four or
five companies that have full control
and and specifically why is it not a
good outcome I think it's not a good
outcome because for example for creators
okay if you're a Creator right now and
you create you know why do you go why do
you wake up in morning and go to Tik Tok
and Instagram right you go there not
because of the content that Tik Tok and
Instagram produce because of the content
the users produce right and and so how
does Tik Tok make money they they make
money through advertising they take all
of the money they make from advertising
they have very di Minimus Creator funds
but they're like less than 1% of their
revenue but outside of that they take
all the money and so they make it very
hard you know music Spotify um it's a
great service I love by the way I love
all these Services they're great but you
know musicians of the 8 million
musicians on Spotify 14,000 make $50,000
a year or more which is roughly the
average American salary and the rest
don't and so this this architecture of
consolidating power in these five
companies is bad for I would argue bad
for cre why do you think the
consumer at scale as a herd allowed that
to happen I think they created better
experiences frankly I think RS like
things like RSS were you remember this
they were clunky you had to set up your
own domain you had to um FR yeah and and
also by the way I I talked about this in
the book I got through it like I I Ed
YouTube as a case study they they did
Heavy subsidization so the original
value proposition of YouTube in 2005
when they launched was you get to it's
really easy to host video and by the way
it's free because we'll pay for it and
and they raised billions of dollars of
venture capital and subsidized it by the
way I wanted to launch Wine Library TV
three years before I did I went to my
tech team and said I want to make wine
videos they're like okay I'm like tell
me how much it's going to cost yeah they
said okay they came back and they said
for every 15minute video you put up
because that was my guess of how long it
they're like for every people that are
going to watch it it was some ason I was
like what and that's what you had to do
if you used RSS right right so that's
why these these so what happened is
Venture Capital the industry I work in
came along and said hey you know what we
think this will be so valuable someday
and YouTube today by the way Wall Street
analy is part of Google but Wall Street
analyst say it's worth $140 billion
right and so the the VC's correctly said
someday the prize is so big that we'll
give you let's call it 10 billion to
subsidize it beat RSS and then
eventually you'll be worth 140 billion
that was sort of the calculation the VCS
of that era made and you know correctly
a lot of them did very well these are
very Val you know meta worth whatever I
don't know 700 billion or I also think
the thing that I knew which is why I bet
the farm on social was attention is the
asset MH and when you're when you're on
garyvaynerchuk.com
you have to muster up the demand all by
yourself when you were on twitter.com
garv you're getting by accident
awareness right all these creators come
to me and they like I ate the platform
so I'm like you were zero in your living
room you went on and you made content
and you paid zero for a wh when you
advertise to get people to know about
something you pay yep and that that was
so valuable that it created the
consolidation yeah I call it come for
the tool stay for the network is sort of
the pattern I call it so you start come
for the tool YouTube says meaning it's
sort of a single like hey you come there
because they subsidize it and it's an
easy do video but then over time it's
because my interpretation have come for
the attention stay for the attention
yeah you know you come because you want
to get that awareness to your point when
you become Beyonce you don't need it as
much but the reality is more and more of
the attention is still there and so like
all of a sudden even traditional media
can't rival that level of attention so
being on in on the cover of People
magazine and being on today's show and
being on Prime Time special on NBC is
not going to outpace contemporary
attention from having incredible success
on Tik Tok y anyway nonetheless go ahead
so okay so that's sort of the problem
statement what I said you know so the
internet started off as this dream of
this Democrat funny I I if I may yeah I
actually when I hear you say this don't
think that you think it's this
catastrophic
problem I think you think of it as it
can just be better yeah that I love look
I love I yes I look I love the internet
I obviously like the average American us
it seven hours a day I'm probably at
that or above like I think it's
incredibly valuable incredibly useful
I've built my career on it it's been
great great for me and so it's just not
as great as it can be yeah I think it
can be I think it can be much better yes
yes and I think that the and my favorite
way to make it better is through
Innovation as opposed to let's say
regulation or something like this like
there's one one school despise you well
that one school of thought would be hey
this is too big let's do things like
block Acquisitions and first of all the
cats out of the bag these companies are
already huge blocking new acquisitions
is not going to I don't think it's going
to move the needle you know maybe you
could break them up it's very hard to
imagine how you could do that the real
game is based on on what is perceived as
you know the real game is new features
stories in stream this but the reality
is the speed in which the big players
can copy a feature be real right
Snapchat like these you know Snapchat
got fortunate that it took meta so long
to create the story function in
Instagram if they had done it two years
earlier yep yeah look and I also think
by the way and I also think it's a
business opportunity if you can go so
you know getting to blockchains like
what what I see a blockchain is as a
it's a piece of infrastructure that lets
you build new Digital Services in which
those Digital Services enable direct
relationships between creators startups
developers and their audiences so for
example what you do with vriends right
when you sell uh you know a VRI a
collectible to uh to to your audience
you pay maybe a small 2% 2 and a half%
fee to a Marketplace or something but
otherwise that money goes to you that
that 97% let's call it of the money
going to you is unheard of in the ex
reverse and even not even close actually
they don't get too and so it's also a
business opportunity if you can go and
create new networks new services that
you can go to these creators and say hey
do you want 97% of the money or do you
want 0% of the money like it's an
interesting business proposal like that
one yeah not a very yes so right I mean
that that's that's ultimately a lot of
the business proposal so blockchains are
a new way to create Digital Services
that compete with things like you know
Facebook and Twitter and games and just
I think of every kind of C Financial
Services payment networks all of them
it's a new way to create Digital
Services Chris you sit here tonight as I
do I assume that it's inconceivable to
you that in the next 20 years that one
of the one of if not the biggest social
network in the world is a decentralized
social network yes I I look I mean
that's I've bet my old me
too obviously do I do believe it but um
and and look I I started to sort of see
it you I've been now in the space for 10
years um and and you know started to see
like to me around 2013 or 14 was when we
started to see that consolidation when
blockchain started to get more
sophisticated and like the technology
started to evolve um so look these
things can take a long time and
obviously it has taken long time that's
been that's been the biggest thing we
you know this is what's nice about being
in this part of our career you know when
we were looking at this stuff in 9969 I
remember saying silly things like I was
a kid dad by the year 2000 everyone's
going to buy every bottle of wine on the
internet this was lack of experience you
didn't you could see it yeah yeah and
yes one day it takes a long time for but
yeah that's the it takes a long time to
build to both build these products the
infrastructure like AI so the first
paper on neural networks is 1943 say
that one more time really slow sorry
because no no I'm not saying I'm doing
this for effect more than appropriate
with your speed I'm trying to keep up
with Gary you're perfect on your speed
I'm saying this for effect because
obviously this is on everyone's mind say
it one more time for the kids in the
back the first time AI was referenced in
paper theur neur networks were invented
in 1943 it was mallic and pits it was a
famous paper you know Allan Turing his
famous Turing test was 1950 his paper um
he even then predicted like 20 years
from now well I forgot exactly the
predictions were but very sophisticated
AI systems there was an AI bubble people
talk about in the 1980s with so-called
expert systems um I started an AI
company in called hunch in 2008 which I
sold eBay in 2011 which I thought I was
like timing it right I was 10 years too
early and you know what actually made AI
happen there were a lot of things that
made AI happen including just brilliant
people you know designing algorithms and
other things but the real thing that
made it happen were gpus which is which
are the processors that it runs on and
by the way why did gpus get so good
because of video games so like the the
real it's a crazy it's kind of a crazy
underappreciated story that video games
are going to bring us you know Advanced
artificial you know why we call them
bugs when there's an issue in there was
literal bugs in the yeah in the vacuum
tubes it it Grace Hopper I think I can't
I I just stumbled on that I don't know
how I missed it in the last 20 years the
fact that that computer in Harvard in
1948 or whatever it was they went in and
something was wrong and there was a moth
in there and they had a pull it out did
you ever see those pictures they have
those big vacuum glass vacuum tubes and
the they were you know insane that is
those things were like I mean they were
like I think they had by the way as I've
got more 1K of memory or something
people even know what that means anymore
that that's kind of where I was why I
jumped in just to Sidetrack to talk
about something interesting lately
because the what's going on because I'm
aware of about the GPU using like the
fire power right the Firepower I'm
trying to figure out now now I'm getting
fascinated by that I'm like okay what
happens when at 100x is now what can we
do that is like that's where it gets fun
with Ai No with something else that I
can't see right now space travel uh
living underwater robot I don't know
things are above my pay grade I'm good
at consumer Behavior with emerging
Technologies the hardcore teex just a a
different
level they continue a lot of these
things are economic phenomenons meaning
that like gpus were already getting
better like why did gpus get better part
of it is physics and smart people but
they needed the money and they had the
money because of video games yes now
they have a lot more money because of AI
and so they're going to get even better
and better that makes sense so like
there's just fly wheels to kick in right
and and they're really I think primarily
people talk about Moors law yes and
that's important but that's sort of how
how many generally refers to how many
trans dener scaling is called how many
transistors can you pack onto like
smaller and smaller area but really
there's this broader thing that happens
across networking storage all areas of
computing you know just the connectivity
and that's an economic phenomenon why is
your iPhone so amazing today is partly
because the iPhone's gotten better it's
partly because the apps have gotten
better but the two reinforced each other
right it's because the first iPhone came
out somebody created snap and Uber and
you know the entrepreneurs created these
Services the services became popular
that then gave Apple you know sold more
phones gave them more money they went
out and made a better camera that made
Instagram especially when you're taking
a 30% all these it's all these fly
wheels and we're in a flywheel with AI I
believe we're in a flywheel with
blockchains now blockchains are getting
better the apps are getting better the
infrastructure is getting better like
you know like the they have a natural
Network effect the more people that use
what's what's the biggest thing that
people are missing about this blockchain
phenomenon in general public that's a
little bit more educated not somebody
who has no no but what do you think is I
think I think that there's some
self-inflicted wounds here due to the
the the crypto industry which is the
kind of speculative and casino aspects I
I have a part in the book where I call
it the casino versus the computer M and
so the idea is there sort of two
cultures right there's the culture which
I write about I tried to I hope this
will be the you know the book people
reference when they when they think
about the comp you know the productive
uses of blockchains the blockchains that
how do you use blockchains to create new
internet services that that provide a
better internet than the one we have
today that's a more that's an Internet
that rewards creators and developers
that's the productive Vision that I
write about there's another set of
people who I think have taken like
tokens are an important part of this
nfts tokens like ethereum that
[Music]
eum
computer ACC and
it's remember I was talking about
subsidies of YouTube they don't have
external sources of funding so it funded
itself through the token so the token
plays a productive use in the system but
there's a set of people who have taken
these tokens out of these contexts and
like SPF and FTX would be the extreme
example put it on a website and make it
into a gambling thing and that gets all
this media attention there's scams and
fraud and then that just kind of of
really really sulles the image of the
space that's right and look and some of
this is you know I I think is
self-inflicted there are people that you
know that that I know that are you know
people get excited by trading and this
and so there's nothing wrong with
speculating things it's the same thing
like Wall Street right like there's like
it's what about alcohol if you misuse
something and like Wall Street like look
the the real purpose of the stock market
is to provide efficient allocation of
capital to help companies build products
that's right a buy product of that is
you have hedge funds and speculation and
that does play an important role I'm not
anti like trading right like trading
plays a role it plays a role in price
Discovery and liquidity and other things
but but but in crypto I think we put the
cart before the horse yes right we mixed
the two like well it happened with web
one it was just done with the stock
prices right web one had its own had own
version it was just it wasn't full
consumer like we are now but like it was
full consumer I mean well what I mean by
that was in
1997 the friction to buy 30 shares of
pet.com that was in like there was too
much friction but it was happening I
mean that that that wave that that
Financial wave was retail driven in the
90s yes it was right E Trade right oh
yeah there was ads every minute on TV
about trading and very similar um so
look I think that I think that kind of
Casino culture has has really soled the
blockchain kind of movement right the
general P definitely nfts yeah you know
I do think Bitcoin is as a brand is
doing well in the scheme of things
definitely nfts yeah um but more
importantly even if nfts and every
cryptocurrency had a great brand right
this second I still think the majority
of people don't even understand the
underlining aspects of the blockchain
and how profound it will be for proof
well this is this is partly why I wrote
the book right because I've done I've
gone around I've been in the space for
10 years I've had God knows how many
conversations um trying to talk about
this like I you know you wrote this
mainly for yourself you're like here
just read this right like instead just
you just like look I'm by the way for
the listeners like I I have been a
longtime proponent of blog I blogged for
years yes I've been a longtime believer
that like most business books shouldn't
be books they should be blog posts okay
just so you know like I wrote a book I
know that I wrote a book begrudgingly
because I really feel and by the way
this is 230 pages I cut out another 230
50 pages like I wrote a book that
begrudgingly because meaning that it's
the only way I decided to really
properly explain this topic this is just
this is a topic that you just need the
history of the internet you need some
context um I just it just I think
there's really no other way to explain
this fully and properly without it's the
only reason it's the only reason I
understand it so I could not even
comprehend understanding it if you don't
understand the history ofet so I that's
why when you told me I was like I mean
that's the first couple chapters are
like a really quick run through the
history of the internet and and and they
are basically what I would say is people
like Gary people like me people like my
partners at the the senior you know like
Mark andri and other people I work with
like they would know this already it's
sort of taken for granted that that
these basic things I kind of argue that
like yeah like when you invent the
browser like literally you had to be a
super nerd by my standards in high
school to know how to go on the internet
before there was a browser yeah like
normal people are like what I can't
write code how the [__] what are you
talking about one Z like I like no no I
like ebay.com enter yes understand 12794
like no yeah really real talk I know it
sounds ludicrous but like when I was in
high school and I heard of like some kid
out of modem and and it was like but it
was like literally the most nerdy
sophisticated knowledgeable kid our
schol for you know one of the best
selling books in the 90s this is after
Mosaic it was a book in the bookstore
how to get on the internet oh yeah like
because it was like you had to download
drivers and windows that's of course why
AOL became they literally said finally
it's so hard we're going to send you CDs
because this is just a nightmare you had
to literally go and be like hacker just
to install the windows driers I realized
email marketing was going to be big yeah
and in 1997 every human that walked into
the Wine Library I was that bought
serious wine I was like would you like
to join our email newsletter half of
them didn't know what he it was and 25%
of the the remaining 25% there was 25%
that knew would say something like yeah
my email is
AOL yahoo.com like they they didn't have
it calibrated the only reason was by way
the only reason 25% knew is by being in
Short Hills Milbourne New Jersey I had a
lot of guys GSS that worked in the stock
market and they were the ones that
actually knew their you know their email
that was it yeah it it's profound and
that's where we are now the amount of
people that say the silliest thing the
same way I joke about AOL aty yahoo.com
and we all laugh the things people are
saying now about nfts crypto like hot
takes not grounded in knowledge is why a
book is needed and look like n to take
nfts a little bit since you know that's
that's what you're working in like nfts
are so the way I think of an nft is and
I have whole section on the book if
people are interested but the the um nft
is so one of the key things that
blockchains enable is they enable
ownership that's why the book's called
read write own they allow they allow new
new services to be created where the
users and creators and software
developers can have their little plot of
land again okay and and nft is is
essentially a little plot of land right
it's a little thing you can own and it's
a very you can put anything on that plot
of land now it so happened that you know
nfts by the way the standard wasn't
developed wasn't finalized until 2020 so
this is a four-year-old technology
people know like okay so it's really
early and what happens often with
Technologies like say this social
networking for example is they there's
sort of the essence of the technology
like what it will be long term and then
there's the way it arrives so like early
social networking right what was Twitter
really today we know what Twitter really
is it's a global messaging system that
you can talk about politics and culture
and business when it arrives it was
nerds talking about the burrito they had
a lunch right and that was it was and it
was widely kind of derided and mocked in
like let's call it 20067 that was my
whole career no I mean it was liter and
by the way my first if you go back and
look at our early tweets we probably
were nerds talking about what we have
for lunch like it was actually an
accurate charact Char characterization
but there was another it wasn't wasn't
the full potential there was also
another Insight I people literally would
joke to me because I was very bullish on
it I was an early investor in it I said
uh they're like who cares if you're
walking the dog and my answer used to be
everyone yeah there is another thing
like yes you could talk about politics
this but like but people are interested
in people yeah like right now someone's
posting walking the dog and people
replying like what kind of breed that's
cool what that like well and your
argument was don't confuse like the
early adopters correct with like don't
over over over rotate on who the first
people just because they're a bunch of
nerds very I mean look at Instagram
Instagram was for photography yeah like
these things take on lives of their own
yeah and then they and then as they grow
they kind of grow into what they really
are and so what nfts really are it's a
way for you to have to to create
something it could be anything it could
be a collectible item it could be
something it could be a wedding
certificate it could be something yes
that ties to the kind of real world it
could be an asset in a video game you
could be an identifier on a social
network like so instead of being cix on
Twitter I own my own it can be anything
and and you know it's a general Tech
sort of Technology it's an atomic unit
of ownership is what an nft is and so a
lot of people that are negative about it
today they look at some of the things
that happen in 2021 2022 and you know
some of the ridiculous prices and other
kinds of things and they say oh this
must be a ridiculous technology but of
course what they what I would argue is
they should look past that and look at
what it really is and what it could
become right and it's going to become I
I think like I think it's an incredibly
like the idea the fact that you could
own something and nobody can forge it
nobody can touch it it can't burn down
in a house you know how much paper was
lost in fires and really screwed up a
human how many people lost our safety
deposit key like real stuff and like do
we really think in 20 years I likeing
around my passport I'm scared every time
I'm with it and do we really think in 20
years that people will be you know
collecting physical things the way that
they do I mean that'll still exist but
digit of course things are going to
become you're love this I did a podcast
yesterday called the retirement home so
six 80-year-old individuals interviewed
me and I I make all my predictions AK
quick actions based on history yeah
hence what we're talking about here and
I talked to them about when the credit
card started to really penetrate culture
that's funny what' they say no they just
said you're right like basically it was
one big actually Dustin walked in the
elevator was like what do you think
because he knows I've been dying to get
more time with people in their 80s yeah
and his answer was interesting he said
to me it it was cool to like know your
stuff is like what did you say like that
you're stu they confirm the things that
been say the stuff he's been listening
to me Yap about for five years he
doesn't have the context for nor when he
looks at me he's like why do you know
that or why do you think you didn't live
it here people lived it and when you
could see people's body when I was like
Hey gang tell these kids like what it
was like when the credit card came out
and you were like no way am I going to
use this what do that even and they were
like yeah and like how weird it was and
like you have to have your cash on you
like when I say I don't want my passport
on me I mean it it could be I want my
passport to be an nft on the US
government blockchain and call it a day
like I don't need it destroyed or stolen
it's a pain in the
ass and you know by the way like uh you
know with the rise of AI as an example
like can you TR like video has been the
ground truth of the Internet it's been
the one thing you can kind of you can
kind of believe Society you can kind of
believe of society very and now with
deep fakes can you can you still believe
video I mean it's already the question
it's a question mark and three years
from now by the way oh it's over it's
over and so one of the beautiful things
you can do with the blockchain actually
have a section on this actually you
inspired me on that one because you've
been talking about it thank you and so
it's one of the sections at the toward
the end of the book I go through a bunch
of like application use cases um but
defix so like a blockchain is a perfect
way to keep an audit Trail and
essentially like the New York Times can
attest to like this video being real and
it's an immutable a audit Trail that's a
great I I think the great use for a
blockchain I think there's a lot of
really interesting use cases for
blockchains that are kind of
counterbalances to what will happen with
ai ai is also going to make by the way
content creation like creating an
illustration already done this
essentially it's going to be Costless
that's right why is somebody going to
pay an illustrator um when they can do
it through AI now will that will that
kill off the illustration business like
I don't think so but I think they need
to they need to adjust their product Oh
it's huge and they need to start leaning
into being communities and what you're
doing right like because you not someone
could generate a new image of of a
vfriend correct and it's not going to
matter to you because it's not the real
V friend correct right you could explain
I should let you be doing the talking
here world ofi like your business model
becomes much much more important in the
world of AI I would of course I I you
know we talked about this we you know
over a flight or a dinner like the AI of
it all is going to accelerate people's
aha moment to the value of the
blockchain Y I mean it's profound and in
a world where people are struggling with
trust of big corporations and Trust of
government like it is actual human
Nirvana decentralized place that shows
truth how do you know it's a real person
how do you know like captas you have to
pick how many fire click on all the fire
hydras like that's over like the
computer can do that I can't wait for
Because by the way I sometimes miss one
when I miss a caption I have to do it
again I'm like the bike was not really
in the scene it's so absurd we live in
2024 and that the answer to figuring out
something as a human is like are there
like how many bikes are in this photo
like it's just not the right answer to
these problems um by the way fishing
authentication like this I I had a one
of my partners he was tweeting about
about it um Martin he he had a uh one of
his family members was had a phone call
with his voice with using Ai and said
hey I need you to send me money and that
that's that's already here I mean that's
you can do you can take someone's
snippet of their voice and then
replicate yeah replicate it so like
we're going to need system yeah imagine
this hello you know and they got to take
over your no you don't know the number
but a lot of people pick that
up comes up as yeah you're right I'm in
big trouble you need to text me like
it's going to yeah you leave a voicemail
so that people not going to believe
anything I think in a couple years
they'll have it interactive like I can
be speaking into the thing and in real
time it'll be making it so I could be
talking but it's we have that now yeah
for people so so by there's an answer to
this which is cryptography right which
just cryptography on blockchains you can
have systems build systems where you can
we have it we walk around like we walk
around with a you know with a touch ID
in our pocket and it's not that hard to
connect that to a bunch of other systems
including blockchains to make sure that
we can authenticate video and text and
voice and all these other things and in
fact we have a bunch of like we we're
working with Sam Alman he's got a
startup called worldcoin which is
exactly that proof of personhood using
blockchains right and so like there's a
bunch of really interesting use cases so
I think the the stuff in the book you
asked me in the beginning what why now I
think part of it is the consolidation of
the internet I think part of it is AI
which look I'm very we're bullish on AI
I think it's awesome our firm invests a
lot in it but it's a centralizing
technology yes it will reinforce the
strength of these companies it's the
extreme centralization yeah it it it's a
super powerful it's a super powerful
thing but it requires lots of data lots
of capital lots of compute and the big
companies have that and it's going to
reinforce that power and blockchain in
my mind is the one kind of credible kind
of counterweight to that to that
movement and so it becomes more
important than ever what what have we
not you know obviously especially when
we get together we just went like I knew
we would I I had coffee Red Bull I was
like I got to get Gary V level clock
speed here n you do just great yourself
brother you need to be Chris Dix and out
all the time what did we not touch on in
our r ranting here that is either in the
book that you'd like to make sure people
know and uh or something that um you
just want people to know from this uh
this interview and and one more time
everybody if you're listening I mean
this open up your phone right now and go
to your favorite bookstore there's one
or two at this point back to
consolidation uh read write own I I just
know my audience very well I think I
have a good track record with all of you
of like books cuz you know I love when
people get educated I still book form
when I think about your knowledge cuz I
know you from afar and now more and more
close when I think that that can be had
on your opinion on this for 20 bucks or
whatever the hell this is getting
discounted to on Amazon that is profound
I still think books are like the great
knowledge you agree with that I I like
this by the way I have a book coming out
in May Day trading attention I just
order this is like thank you brother
this is the secret of everything for me
and I really did it you know writing a
book made me really appreciate books in
a way in fact I I finished the book
basically in October and I think I have
read more books now in the last three
months since because I I because you
realize what you did and you're like
wait other people are doing this too
like obviously this isn't the full 25
years of knowledge but it really is kind
of the best parts of it it's sort of
like and it took like I spent 12 months
I got up every morning you know I spent
four hours a day I also had a lot of
really smart colleagues who helped me um
and so like it it it was I didn't
realize how much work it was going to be
to well it was it was work for you and
by the way this one was my hardest work
too and I've written a bunch that have
done really well I think this one was
work for you because you know it matters
you know that it's complicated just like
I know marketing is complicated and you
know that you've been fortunate enough
to maybe be able to synthesize it and
that require like that requires real
effort because you can go long-winded
here you might miss something here and
there's a sense of responsibility yeah
look like so like I'll tell you too I S
I started this after kind of the FTX and
a bunch of the the scandals and the
other of stuff and at first I was sort
of depressed I was like wow all this
work over this stuff and then these Bad
actors spoil it and then I sort of said
to myself well let's look at it
optimistically which is I've never been
involved in a area of I've been involved
in technology a long time but I've never
been involved in one where the gap
between the public perception and and
what I think is the reality is so wide
and instead of feeling sorry for myself
that that there's that wide Gap why
don't I see it as an opportunity which
is I could write maybe hopefully write
the book to fill that Gap and that's
what so that's what kept me getting up
every day for brother honestly you know
this like Bill Gates was the most
powerful technologist of the time and
was sitting on television making fun of
the
internet yep like it's a fat yep like I
you know back to Mark and you you know
he wrote a book called the road ahead
which yep and it was came out in '95 and
the word the web didn't appear correct
and so then he wrote a new version and
he bought up all the old versions so
they wouldn't find them you can find
them on eBay now insane is that true yes
that's true that's insane that's true
this is why I don't like to predict I
just like to talk and I'm obviously he's
a genius and like I'm
not I'm making point that like it's very
me what I'm saying is maybe this is the
thing that has the biggest Gap but but
for the people that were fully bought
into
electricity when it was invented
obviously the person who invented it and
the early Believers of
it do you know how sad that first decade
was when most of the general public
thought that if you brought technology
into your home you were bringing demons
into your home y let me just you know
I've given you a lot of history lessons
electricity by the majority of the
general public was viewed as a
voodoo Spirit thing do you know where
the first electricity was in United
States it's right New Jersey no well
that's where that's where he was but it
was JP Morgan at his house with the
library today on 36th Street was the
first house in the United States that
had he put a generator in the back he he
he wired up he he he was a venture
capitalist who ate his own dog food he
literally was the first person to have
it and it would smoke black smoke
everywhere and all the neighbors
complained and then they went and wired
up Wall Street yeah no but it was yeah
of course Thomas
Edison no but he he was the investor in
it but um no you're right it was wild
sit here and we're like oh man I wish
people understood the blockchain [__]
electricity by way it's Gypsy there's a
great book it's it's like a cartoon book
it's called I think it's called the war
on fun or something and it's basically
every it's basically the argument is
every single thing in the world at some
point it's first adopted by teenagers
and then adults hate it and it happened
with you know going back to Socrates he
was anti- writing that's right the novel
was originally considered debased you
know form of like you know Etc the
bicycle was very controversial
Kaleidoscope the ear you know early cars
you had to disassemble your car the red
flag FL laws they're called like there's
a long history of by the way early
internet cryptography this was a massive
debate in the 90s you know the the
128bit uh Netscape was classified as
Munitions by the US government until
1999 I think it was was illegal to
export 128bit Netscape they had a 32-bit
version that you could export because
strong cryptography was considered
Munitions right and and people like Mark
andreon my partner Mark andreon and Ben
Horowitz had to go in front of you know
down to DC and basically say they would
say well why would someone want to
encrypt something unless they're a
criminal and they said because someday
it doesn't happen today people will buy
things on the internet and they'll need
it to be private but that doesn't happen
today so you know you want us to make a
law that allows for criminal activity
when there's this thing that might
happen someday like literally this was a
major debate people can look it up the
Clippers chip like I know it was a major
kind of debate uh I think if the
blockchain debate today is similar to
that and that it's like this you know I
think people will someday when we're 80
as you were talking about they'll be
like come on no one was really against
they were really trying to ban
blockchains and tokens and be like yeah
they were no no you're you're you're
exaggerating it that's right I think
that I think that will happen please
everyone go out this is as infatic as
I've been in the history of my podcast
this is a book you must pick up I don't
give a crap if you ever do anything on
the blockchain or crypto this is for
life this is understanding that history
can show you the future and will make
you more of a Maybe person instead of a
no person and there is a direct
correlation to profession success and
spiritual happy personal success when
you start eliminating no from your
vocabulary and create maybe maybe leads
to no but no but sometimes it leads to
yes no always leads to no and it keeps
you away from everything that is fun and
good Chris thank you so much thank you
Gary that you're the best thank
you